des heures jusque tard dans la nuit
avenue de clichy dans la capitale les
forces de l'ordre sont mobilisés face au
feu et aux barricades érigées par des
manifestants la mobilisation a débuté en
fin de journée de toute l'île de france
les manifestants ont convergé vers un
lieu symbolique
le tribunal de grande instance de paris
une foule compacte environ vingt mille
personnes selon la préfecture de police
après quelques heures de rassemblement
pacifique la situation s'est tendue pour
aboutir à des affrontements avec les
forces de l'ordre non loin du
rassemblement des manifestants ont
bloqué le périphérique avant d'être visé
par des tirs de gaz lacrymogène le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner à lui réagi dans un tweet
la violence n'a pas sa place en
démocratie
rien ne justifie les débordements
survenus ce soir à paris alors que les
rassemblements de voie publique sont
interdits pour protéger la santé de tous
je félicite ceux des forces de sécurité
et secours pour leur maîtrise et leur
sang froid
le rassemblement était organisé par le
comité de soutien à adama traoré mort à
24 ans après son arrestation en 2016 une
mobilisation non déclarés et qui faisait
bien sûr écho à une autre ça
rassemblement qu'on fait suite à tous
les événements qui a eu la semaine
dernière celle qui arrive juste avant
c'est la mort de georges frêche c'est
tom noah notre frère des scènes qui vont
en tout cas
j'ai calqué sur la mort de mon petit
faire aussi bien
je regarde tout le poids de 3 kg et même
au delà
cette manifestation a eu lieu alors
qu'une expertise commandée par la
famille d'adama traoré a mis en lumière
la responsabilité des gendarmes lors de
l'arrestation qui lui a coûté la vie
dévoilée hier par ses proches elle
contredit trois expertises médico
judiciaire favorable à l'aversion des
forces de l'ordre des manifestations
contre les violences policières ont eu
lieu ailleurs en france notamment à
lille lyon ou marseille